zdf heute live herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer eine woche
nach der flutkatastrophe kämpfen die
menschen in den krisengebieten immer
noch gegen die schlammmassen
die zahl der toten alleine im kreis
ahrweiler ist auf 123 gestiegen
viele menschen werden noch vermisst und
die hoffnung sie lebend zu finden ist
gering und so gut wie unmöglich da noch
jemanden lebend raus zu holen
so groß die zerstörung ist so groß ist
auch die hilfsbereitschaft und einer der
seit tagen hilft und im internet eine
kleine berühmtheit geworden ist von
vielen wird er der held der stunde
der held dieser tage genannt ist jetzt
bei uns in der sendung markus
wipperfürth schön dass sie bei uns sind
und zeit für uns gefunden haben
herr wipperfürth wir machen das unter
anderem auch deshalb mit ihnen weil wir
sehen wie groß ihr einsatz vor ort ist
und wie groß der zuspruch ist und bevor
wir einsteigen ein kommentar von gestern
ein user namens kaleck lover hat
geschrieben liebes zdf guckt euch mal
die facebook seite vom lohnunternehmen
markus wipperfürth an
er ist seit dem ersten tag vor ort am
helfen und dokumentierten mit videos was
da wirklich abgeht jetzt sehe ich gerade
dass herr wipperfürth nicht mehr zu
sehen ist was natürlich schade ist aber
natürlich in einem katastrophengebiet
auch nicht besonders verwunderlich weil
natürlich auch das handynetz das
stromnetz das telefonnetz dort nicht
stabil ist ich versuche mal während wir
versuchen die leitungen wieder
aufzubauen
den kommentar von garik lava weiter
vorzulesen er lobt nämlich den einsatz
von herrn wipperfürth er sagt er
dokumentiert mit diesen videos was da
wirklich abgeht respekt an ihn und an
die die in den gebieten so eine
riesengroße arbeit leisten teils
kostenlos aber sicher nicht umsonst ich
finde diese leute dürfen nicht unerwähnt
bleiben
wir freuen uns über eure fragen und
kommentare wie immer in die kommentare
oder an die hoffentlich ein
endete und bekannte e mail adresse unter
ist er wieder herr wipperfürth wo sind
sie und was machen sie gerade
also ich bin hier in balzheim und wir
fahren hier gerade ja immer noch
bauschutt weg und sperrmüll den die
leute jetzt aus ihren häusern raus
backen
wer wir sind hier mit ganz vielen
landwirtschaftlichen fahrzeugen auch mit
lkws also der ganze mittelstand ist hier
vertreten und hier gemeinsam auf und
dass es so unsere arbeiten die wir seit
sieben tagen jetzt machen und viele
kollegen die arbeiten rund um die uhr
sie wird auch nachts gefahren es ist
wirklich beeindruckend was hier
geleistet wird also dass so was habe ich
noch nie erlebt das ist einfach
gigantisch
ja ich hab's eingangs gesagt für viele
sind sie der held der stunde sie sind
eigentlich lohnunternehmer aus der nähe
von köln
wie kam das dazu was hat den ausschlag
gegeben dass sie gesagt haben ich fahr
dahin ich muss da helfen also wir haben
mehrere ride anlagen und es war ja
bekannt dass ein unwetter kommt mit ca
200 litern pro quadratmeter wir haben
dann die reitanlagen so abgesichert dass
er zwei tage lang gedauert wir pumpen
installiert und alles dass wir sozusagen
relativ safe run ich habe dann auch live
videos gemacht
trotzdem sind die reichen anlagen
abgesoffen wie man so schön sagt aber
durch die ganze pumpentechnik hat mir
das relativ schnell im griff
dann hatte ich auch noch facebook eine
warnung herausgegeben an die eifel weil
ich immer alles auf dem satellitenbild
verfolgen konnte und hab gesagt was auf
das kommt gleich zu uns und die ganzen
bauern hatten drei tage vorher schon
immer kommuniziert das was ganz
schlimmes im anmarsch ist und die haben
mich alle auch darauf hingewiesen magst
du bist in köln passt auf bei dir wird's
richtig übel
ja und deshalb musste ich am nächsten
morgen als ich dann radio gehört habe
ich stehe um 5 auf das kann dann schon
hier das ist hier echt schlimm war
dann habe ich direkt mit einem freund
telefoniert aus fulda
gartenbau gedreht und er sagt ich war
sofort mit fünf leuten und dem radlader
ich gesagt okay dann komme ich hier mit
der kabel dann können wir vielleicht
irgendwie erste hilfe leisten
wir gucken mal gerade auf ihre
facebook-seite wir schalten mal kurz um
auf das notebook hier im studio und
sehen quasi seit sie angefangen haben
posten sie unendlich viel material von
da sie machen live-videos sie posten
bilder es gibt unendlich viele
kommentare 27 millionen 3,7 millionen
mal wurden ihre videos inzwischen
geklickt und auch die kommentare
darunter das sind unendlich viele da
kommen wir gleich noch drauf was sie da
alles vor ort organisieren und was sie
da alles machen aber zuerst mal wenn wir
diese bilder hier sehen als sie da
hingekommen sind und das zum ersten mal
gesehen haben das ausmaß der
zerstörungen wie haben sie da reagiert
also ich war wirklich geschockt ich habe
so was im leben noch nie gesehen
wir sind hier angekommen um bei der
feuerwehr haben gefragt ob wir helfen
können die wussten dass wir kamen das
war angekündigt dann haben wir uns eine
adresse gegeben wir sind hier unter
gefahren
da waren dann auch feuerwehrleute und es
war ein riesenwust an bäumen autos
gastanks gasflaschen drei meter hoch man
konnte überhaupt ein ende sehen und ich
habe so was im leben noch nie gesehen
wir wussten dass hier eine richtige
katastrophe grad stattgefunden hat es
gab ja keine rettungswege zu den häusern
und man hat ja gar keine möglichkeit
hinzu kommen die leute rausholen
deshalb haben wir gesagt der film hat
man dann eben mit seinem radlader wir
müssen möglichst schnell hier gassen
bilden oder gassen reinbauen das im
prinzip die rettungskräfte die
möglichkeit haben da hinzukommen
und dann haben wir mit zwei
feuerwehrleuten angefangen diese gasse
zu bilden und irgendwann sagt man die
zwei jungs wir sind jetzt weg und wenn
ihr eine leiche fände dann sagt bescheid
dann kommt die polizei raus und dann
waren wir auch dem zeitpunkt fünf tage
lang oder noch länger komplett allein
hier
es war keine feuerwehr da es war kein
thema weder es war keine bundeswehr da
ich habe die ganze nacht durchgearbeitet
es war kein wasser hier es war kein dixi
klos drei tage lang ich musste hier
schlafen mit flüssigkeiten die ich an
den händen hatte nur um schnell diese
gassen zu bilden es war wirklich richtig
übel und ich dachte okay die ganzen
feuerwehren hierhin unterwegs waren
die haben die wahrscheinlich woanders
eingeteilt und ich habe jetzt im
nachhinein gilt dass die alle weg
geschickt worden
also es war eine unverschämtheit
eigentlich was hier stattgefunden hat
wir hier eine leiche finden also das ist
ein unding so was mit was wir hier
konfrontiert worden
ich habe vor zwei tagen das erste mal
hier ein sanitäts und zwei tage nun muss
man dazu sagen das ist natürlich der
eindruck den sie vor ort haben es ist ja
nicht so dass niemand da ist es kann
sein dass in der situation von der sie
berichten gerade niemand da war das ist
ja nun nicht so dass nicht die
bundeswehr die polizei das thw und
andere kräfte nicht vor ort im einsatz
sind aber das was sie jetzt schildern
sind natürlich ganz persönliche
erlebnisse die sie vor ort haben es gibt
über sorry ich habe noch ein kommentar
von marc ritter über facebook der sagt
respekt für die freiwilligen die jetzt
auch noch dumm angegangen werden von
menschen die nichts beitragen
herr wipperfürth organisiert und
motiviert opfer und helfer der staat
versagt vor ort würden sie das auch so
sehen absolut unterstreichen wir haben
ja gar nicht gewusst warum uns nicht
geholfen wird
ich weiß nicht ob sie sich vorstellen
können wie jemand aussieht der fünf
kilometer hier runter gespielt wird mit
mit tonnenschweren bäumen und uns hat
keiner zur seite gestanden wir haben ja
alles aufgeräumt
das haben alles die die bauern die
bauunternehmer die die handwerker und
und garten landschaftsbau gemacht und
ich dachte das wäre nur hier so weit die
anderen woanders auf kommunale habe ich
irgend gehört dass die ganzen einheiten
weg geschickt worden
ich habe bis jetzt keine nur noch von
der einsatzleitung oder so wir arbeiten
hier komplett auf eigene faust und dass
das ist ein komplettes versagen ja wie
funktioniert denn die zu
mit den behörden vor ort es gibt ja eine
eine einsatzzentrale
es gibt behörden die vor ort das
kommando haben die auch delegieren die
koordinieren
gibt es da eine zusammenarbeit auch
zwischen ihnen und der bundeswehr zum
beispiel also vor fünf tagen hätte ich
ihnen jetzt geantwortet es wäre schön
wenn sie mir mal die nutzer von wege
geben und einfach mal sagen gut diese
zentrale ist seit zwei tagen seitdem
frau klöckner hier war funktioniert das
das ist wirklich eine sehr gute
zusammenarbeit mit den kräften die hier
sind und das funktioniert seit zwei
tagen erst und wie gesagt drei tage ohne
sich die hände waschen zu können
obwohl man hier wie gesagt flüssigkeiten
an den händen hat
dixi klo gestellt zu kriegen also das
sollte eigentlich schon jede
rettungseinheit irgendwie hinkriegen
und das ist wir haben auch kritik die
wir sehen im netz auch an ihrem einsatz
eine lese ich mal vor die habe ich auf
twitter gefunden
da schreibt jemand da haben wipperfürth
und co erreicht was sie wollten durch
die verbreitung falscher tatsachen
verzerrung und teils fragwürdigen
äußerungen macht er die
hilfsorganisationen zu deppen während
die landwirte und bauunternehmer als die
alleinigen helden dastehen wie reagieren
sie auf diesen kommentar ich mache die
verantwortlichen die ganz oben sitzen
verantwortlich für das was hier passiert
ist alle anderen mit denen wir zu tun
haben die wollten wir sind aber nicht
geschickt worden
die durften nicht runter jetzt sind
deprimiert wieder nach haus gefahren
wir wussten ja was hier los ist ich hab
es ja extra gepostet wird das kann jeder
nachvollziehen und jeder kann in den
filmen gucken ob er irgendwo offizielle
personen sie einfach mal schauen ob man
irgendwo einen sieg und man wird sich
wundern
okay aber herr wipperfürth da muss ich
sie jetzt sorry aber das wie gesagt das
mag ihr eindruck seien aber alleine
also ich kann ihnen jetzt 100
fernsehsender aus der ganzen welt
berichten von al dschasira über das
öffentlich-rechtliche fernsehen bis zum
privatfernsehen n24 die jetzt welt
heißen n tv wir alle haben die bilder
gesehen und wir sehen auch dass sie
nicht alleine gelassen werden wir haben
gerade auch darüber gesprochen was sie
für schreckliche bilder sehen mussten
sie als helfer und auch viele andere die
im einsatz waren und vor ort sind es
sind aber zum beispiel auch
notfallseelsorger in diesem gebiet
unterwegs und dazu haben wir ein beitrag
gehen können wir uns gemeinsam anschauen
in kreuzberg bei altena sind die
notfallseelsorgerin seit tagen unterwegs
tamara orschler und dunja puschmann
kommen von der caritas und einer
katholischen gemeinde der ort schwer
zerstört die menschen haben
schreckliches erlebt
[Musik]
haben menschen gesehen wie leute einfach
im auto sagt man abgedriftet worden sind
genau menschen deinem haus eingestellt
wurden jetzt drei tragen herausgeholt zu
hören hilfe anbieten organisieren das
ist ihre wichtigste aufgabe
es geht erstmal um stabilisierung ein
bisschen normalität in dieser unnormalen
situation herzustellen auch so ein
bisschen
wieder handlungsfähigkeit in der
einsatzzentrale am nürburgring rund 30
kilometer entfernt laufen die hilferufe
120 notfallseelsorger aus ganz
deutschland betreuen die hochwasseropfer
in einem psychischen ausnahmezustand
wir haben hier noch die besonderheit
dass das natürlich über tage geht jetzt
kommt so langsam auch eine psychische
erschöpfung es wird einfach bewusst was
da passiert ist doch immer wieder kann
das seelsorgeteam helfen zb hier in
kreuzberg eine familie vermisste die
mutter gestern haben sie sie in einem
krankenhaus gefunden
ein lichtblick in diesen schwierigen
zeiten
das war jetzt nur ein beispiel sie sind
nicht alleine vor ort und sie wissen das
auch und es gibt auch große kritik daran
wie die leitung hier organisiert ist und
dass es probleme gibt aber warum okay
vielleicht sie in dieser kleinen
in diesem umfeld das sie sehen können
aber das ist ja eine größere katastrophe
in mehreren orten warum maßen sie sich
an zusagen sie sind da ganz alleine und
es ist niemand vor ort wenn wir sehen
dass andere menschen auch vor ort sind
wir hatten gestern vom drk hier im
studio und einsatzleiter der auch gesagt
hat ich habe dass mein leben lang
gemacht aber das habe ich noch nie
gesehen von der feuerwehr aus meinem
heimatdorf sind freiwillige feuerwehr
die fahnder extra hin die sind vor ort
die kommen wieder zurück und erzählen
ich habe diese bilder noch nie gesehen
es gibt diese menschen es gibt nicht nur
sie warum erwecken sie trotzdem diesen
eindruck und sie werden mir noch
zustimmen das nicht unsere aufgabe sein
kann hier leichen zu finden und dann die
polizei anzurufen ohne dass ein
seelsorger weiß das kann nicht unsere
aufgabe sein oder ohne dass ein feuer
wenn man dabei ist beziehen ihr
gasflaschen raus das haben wir gesehen
ich noch keine kritik an der feuerwehr
die hier wirklich mit uns
zusammenarbeitet das sind super jungs
die wir sind aus dem gleichen grund bei
der feuerwehr besser wir gekommen sind
wir wollten einfach nur helfen und oben
sie ist der thw weggeschickt wurden von
rinteln usw
die sind weg geschickt worden anstatt
hier unten zu uns geschickt worden um
das wir hier gemeinsam gesagt seit zwei
tagen funktioniert das sehen wir hier
wirklich gemeinsam aufarbeiten das
funktioniert sehr gut mit der bundeswehr
und mit allen weil die einfach dürfen
aber die dürften nicht und das können
sie auch alles nach und das können sie
überprüfen lassen
ganz einfach mit den fall es gibt ganz
deprimierte feuerwehrleute weil die
einfach wieder nach hause geschickt
worden
da kritisiere ich überhaupt kein das
sind klasse jungs die sind die sind die
fachleute ich wollte nur meine lkw hier
zur verfügung stellen mit mehr als
fahrer dass wir material wegfahren ich
wollte auf anweisung arbeiten und nicht
hier auf eigene faust die sachen machen
hier ist bei in dem bereich wo wir
gearbeitet haben richtig viel
schiefgegangen sehr viel können sie sie
haben das ansatzweise schon geschildert
aber was hat sie am meisten bewegt in
den letzten tagen von dem was sie was
sie gesehen haben
also mich haben wirklich die menschen
die hier vor ort wohl bewegt diese mauer
und dieses gefühl im prinzip alles
verloren zu haben
es gibt menschen die noch nicht mal mehr
schuhe also was wir hier ankamen und und
die wirklich die erste etage und ein
komplett die war zerstört es gibt nichts
mehr
und das hat mich wirklich bewegt aber
mich hat auch bewegt wenn man dann hier
mit problemen oder die die die bauern
die hier gearbeitet haben dann eben mit
sachen konfrontiert wurden und da eben
auch jetzt probleme mit haben also die
ganze situation hin war schwierig aber
ich habe auch was positives bewegt wir
haben in der gemeinschaft gefunden die
ich so noch nie erlebt habe das ist hier
den arbeiten hand in hand
jeder weiß was er hier macht ich glaube
hier sind ich weiß nicht 1000 traktoren
bagger und alles oder noch mehr in dem
ganzen gebiet und die leute können
perfekt mit den maschinen umgehen das
ist wirklich wir haben hier was
geleistet das ist unglaublich ich habe
das alles dokumentiert ich hätte nie im
leben gedacht so was wir menschen so
fähig sind wenn man in so eine situation
gerät wir wir essen jetzt zusammen mit
den leuten die hier wohnen die kochen
für uns wir essen gemeinsam
wir haben alles selbst organisiert hier
wir haben duschen organisiert wir haben
toiletten für die leute und organisiert
das haben wir alles gemacht dass hier
was reinkommt und und das ist ja
wirklich ein riesen miteinander also man
hat schon ein schlechtes gewissen dass
man irgendwann weg weil man sich wie so
ein kleines zahnrad in den ganzen
getriebe dass das hält das ganze hier am
laufen und dass man den leuten hoffnung
geben kann dass es irgendwie weitergeht
wir bemühen uns wirklich hier möglichst
schnell alles aufzuräumen dass es wieder
vorwärts gehen kann
die leute und wie gesagt die sieben tage
habe ich wirklich auch so mitgenommen
man ist hier in dem zahnrad drin und
wenn man nach hause kommt dann denkt man
über die ganzen sachen eben nach also es
lässt einen nicht mehr los was man
erlebt und das kann sich jeder
vorstellen bei der anzahl leicht und was
man hier auch alles erlebt was es ist
also es ist für uns auch irgendwie so
eine ausnahmesituation
wie gehen sie damit um
haben sie jemanden mit dem sie darüber
reden setzen sie sich abends zusammen
besprechen das noch mal haben sie hilfe
haben sie ansprechpartner
ja ich hatte ja extra aufruf gestartet
wie viele von den bauern sind auch schon
nach hause
im prinzip vorne gearbeitet haben und
ich habe dann gesagt wir können nicht
alleine lassen
die sind schon weg und wie gesagt also
man muss sich hier hilfe hole ich bin
davon überzeugt dass man das nicht
verarbeitet was was man hier mitbekommen
hat also wir wollen jetzt erstmal hier
alles schaffen was geht und dann müssen
wir später gucken wie es weitergeht
wir haben hier ein paar bilder die wir
zeigen wahrscheinlich können sie die
nicht sehen aber wir sehen sie das ist
das material was sie auch über facebook
gepostet haben wie sie da durch die
durch die katastrophengebiete
durchfahren das ist jetzt eine straße
die schon freigeräumt ist wir sehen
müllautos wir sehen großes gerät dort
vor ort können sie nochmal ein bisschen
schildern was auch jetzt die aufgabe in
den nächsten tagen für sie sein wird und
die userinnen und user von denen sie
hier sehr sehr viel mit gefühl und dank
und respekt bekommen die fragen sich
auch wie es weitergeht weil er für das
wochenende wieder neue unwetter auch
vorhergesagt sind ja das ist eben gerade
das bereiten wir jetzt hier vor der
markus zehntel der hat hinten die straße
wieder fehlten 80 meter und genau in der
kurve war die strömung extrem stark und
er sagte wir müssen hier den shop
verbrechen das im prinzip wenn jetzt
wieder wassermassen kommen nicht wieder
alles mitgerissen wird
dann haben wir natürlich müll
lagerplätze hier sind also zehntausende
kubikmeter müll überall die wir hier aus
fahren
wir mussten auch an die ahr gehen und da
müllplätze herstellen und sozusagen die
krone anlegen und da müssen wir jetzt
dass wir da bevor es jetzt wieder stark
geregnet die sachen im prinzip wegfahren
das wird jetzt oben umgelagert wir haben
alle was ihnen hier
das ist wirklich unglaublich an die
ganzen bauunternehmer
nochmals vielen dank man macht einen
aufruf man weiß was bild und alles wird
geliefert aus ganz deutschland wir sind
unternehmer aus süddeutschland aus
norddeutschland
wir haben hier werkstattwagen haben
wagen um hydraulik zu reparieren um die
reifen zu überreden das sind so die
ganzen sachen jemand jemals
lohnunternehmer weiß wenn ich in so
einem material hier farbe dann fahre ich
mir die reifen kaputt und dann muss ich
eben die werkstattwagen hier vor ort
haben sonst stehen wir alle und
tankwagen wir haben hier alles
organisiert und das läuft hier wirklich
gut und unser problem ist jetzt wirklich
der samstag da ist dadurch wieder stark
denken gemeldet und da arbeiten wir
jetzt gerade da dass wir im prinzip das
schützen was wir bis jetzt erreicht
haben und das machen wir immer gemeinsam
wir besprechen das und dann wird es
immer ich habe noch eine frage zu den
freiwilligen helfern weil es meldungen
gibt in den letzten tagen dass vermehrt
auch leute aus der rechten szene in die
gebiete fahren um das sozusagen für sich
zu vereinnahmen um zentren aufzubauen
kinderbetreuung zum beispiel autos durch
die straßen fahren die so aussehen wie
polizeiautos und falschmeldungen
verbreiten wie stehen sie dem gegenüber
also ich habe das selber nicht
mitgekommen
kurioserweise ist man ja wirklich hier
in der nacht im durchschnitt drei
stunden schlafen im durchschnitt lich
und wir setzen wirklich alles daran dass
dass wir möglichst schnell hier
aufgeräumt haben und trotzdem kriegt man
irgendwelche botschaften e mails oder so
ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen also
ich glaube ist schon irgendwas wo sich
leute profilieren wollen und politik
betreiben wollen das habe ich schon
gemerkt weil man wird ja auch
angesprochen und ich finde dass sowas
von erwerbs kann man schon sagen mit dem
leid der leute hier probiert noch
politik zu betreiben
also das muss ich schon sagen dass das
ich habe da wie gesagt anrufe bekommen
und irgendwas und ich habe das direkt
abgelehnt und es läuft hier so wie wir
das machen also die rechte szene habe
ich nicht gesehen aber ich habe nur
gehört so wie sie das sagen und man
kriegt eben auch viel am telefon mit ich
hatte die letzten tag ich habe mir
einmal gezählt 453 anrufe und ich muss
ja alles regeln obwohl ich nur
treckerfahrer bin ich wollte nur die
erdbeere bedienen also die belastung ist
schon
enorm hoch die anerkennung auch wenn ich
das an der stelle weitergeben darf mary
schreibt über youtube live zdf heute las
markus wissen dass er ein wahnsinns
toller mensch ist und einfach sofort
losgefahren ist um zu helfen
danke also sie haben viele kommentare
bei sich in facebook wahrscheinlich im
sie gar keine zeit zu lesen aber auch
hier in der community ist der respekt
und die anerkennung echt sehr sehr hoch
eine kritische frage noch es gibt auch
meldungen dass sie auf der payroll
bestimmter querdenker stehen das sie mit
spenden unterstützen was sagen sie dazu
also das stimmt nicht da habe ich auch
ein video zu gemacht was einem so alles
nachgesagt wird dass man mit der
bestätigung was hätte oder sonst was ich
wähle distanzieren uns da absolut von
ich wusste nicht wer mich da angerufen
hat es ging darum dass hier ein bagger
abgezogen werden soll ich kenne diese
ganzen leute nicht und dann hatte ich
nur gesagt dass hier wohl ein privater
spender ist dass die bagger hier stehen
bleiben können und weiter arbeiten
können und dann kam dann heraus wer das
war
und dann ist das eben abgelehnt wurde
das sind eben die leute die im
hintergrund mich dann informieren und
sagen immer dass auch das ist ein
querdenker oder irgendwas mich
interessieren die leute alle gar nicht
ich weiß warum ich ein mundschutz tragen
und warum ich mich impfen lasse
ich will ja einfach meine arbeit machen
und dass solche fragen überhaupt kommen
oder dass solche leute sagen im prinzip
ihre ihren ihre denkweise hier mit in
dieses system mehr einzubringen was wir
aufgebaut haben wir wollen ihnen
arbeiten und schaffen und uns nicht mit
solchen sachen beschäftigen
das ist eine unverschämte überlegen sie
mal wie viele stunden ich die die
letzten sieben tage am stück gearbeitet
habe und ich muss mich mit solchen kram
befassen das liegt aber auch daran weil
sich keiner irgendetwas kümmert die
unternehmer wissen nicht ob sie dafür
bezahlt werden der erzähler hat ihr
riesige maschinen stehen
er hat mehr rauchen hier stehen es ist
doch logisch dass wenn ich immer weiter
umsonst arbeiten und es kommt kein
signal von der politik dass die einmal
sagen hört mal auf dann um dann werden
zumindest euro kosten übernommen
ich habe gar keinen arbeiten jetzt schon
seit sieben tagen hier umsonst
ich werde mit sicherheit kleine 17 tage
hier umsonst erreichen können
ich muss auch irgendwie geld verdienen
und da muss man ein signal von der
politik kommen wenn da ein signal kommen
würde dann hätten die ja gar keine
chance hier unternehmer anzusprechen und
zu sagen komm ich übernehme deine kosten
das ist meines erachtens auch wieder
eine sache die die regierung verschlägt
es kommt kein signal dass das
irgendetwas übernommen das geht so auch
mich gut alleine heute hat 200 millionen
euro an soforthilfen für die opfer
beschlossen vom bund die länder sollen
das noch mal verdoppeln und auch ein
wiederaufbau fonds wird aufgesetzt das
ist die hilfe für die opfer und es ist
natürlich davon auszugehen dass auch
längerfristig darüber nachgedacht wird
wie man insgesamt diese katastrophe
aufarbeiten kann wo man fehler gemacht
hat was man verbessern muss und wie man
sich bei all denen wie auch innen
bedankt auch finanziell die sich da so
engagieren
was wünschen sie sich jetzt konkret im
moment am meisten was was braucht es
jetzt also ich wünsche mir konkret am
meisten dass wir einfach unsere arbeit
so jetzt weitermachen wie seit zwei
tagen läuft in zusammenarbeit mit den
ganz mit der bundeswehr dem thw und der
feuerwehr das ist wirklich super jetzt
ist kam mir so vor als wenn die jetzt
los gelassen wurden und dass wir müssen
einfach so weitermachen und ich wünsche
mir dass die ganzen leute die das sind
wirklich jungs aus der landwirtschaft
unsere gewissen beamer mit den maschinen
umgeht das sind alles
landwirtschaftliche maschinen die hier
die gärten reinfahren so kleine maschine
ist man in der gemeinschaft hier weiter
aufräumt mannschaft das sonst nicht das
sind solche mengen die hier zusammen
kommt man rollt irgendwie was weg und
für stunden später liegt schon wieder
dabei dann der erste stock wieder
ausgeräumt wurde
wir sind hier nur am gas geben und am
fahren und wie gesagt die die fahren
hier teilweise die nacht durch und wenn
wir das system irgendwie unterbrechen
dann ich wüsste nicht wer das
geschafften soll
ich bin mir sicher dass wir mit über
1000 maschinen hier dran sind nur um zu
helfen das ist unser gedanke wir wollen
helfen und ich bin kein held oder sonst
irgendwas ich habe das auch gelesen ich
habe auch nur zwei hände
ich habe nur material wirklich mache das
gleiche wie alle anderen auch und jeder
der hier ist er will einfach nur helfen
dass es weitergeht
und das ist so mein wunsch dass man
einfach uns das jetzt zu ende bringen
lässt dass sie unten alles sauber ist
und dass man mal so gemeinsam plant wies
auf die lange frist gehen soll weil
natürlich die massen liegen an müll und
das muss ja auch irgendwie entsorgt
werden ich habe gehört dass eine deponie
eben in brand gegangen ist dann kam die
warnung wir sollten aufpassen dass wir
keine akkus drin haben weil das in die
müllverbrennung geht aber wenn sie hier
so ein schlamm laden oder irgendwas sich
sehen da nichts dran also es gibt noch
ganz viele probleme die hier zu lösen
sind allein bei der entsorgung bevor der
aufbau über anfangen kann und ja ich
wünsche mir einfach dass die leute
irgendwie das gefühl haben dass es
weitergeht und dass das eben nicht
alleine hier stehen sagt markus
wipperfürth der sich zeit genommen hat
für unseren live stream livestream wofür
ich mich sehr herzlich bedanke und enden
möchte mit einem kommentar von klaus
voss gitter über youtube ein dankeschön
an alle helfer die helfen egal ob das
thw feuerwehr drk oder sonst wer ist
vielen dank herr wipperfürth dass sie
bei uns in der sendung waren dankeschön
ihnen liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
zu hause
danke ich fürs zuschauen fürs mitmachen
fürs kommentieren auch sie können helfen
wenn sie möchten am besten über spenden
an das zdf spendenkonto die
informationen darüber finden sie bei uns
auf der homepage und natürlich auch noch
mal in den kommentaren vielen dank dass
sie dabei waren ihnen allen einen
schönen abend